[Applaudissements]
l'agent lui ne serait-ce pas les deux
dernières dates de ton spectacle demain
après demain
exactement je finis mon spectacle après
trois ans et je voudrais remercier tous
les gens qui sont venus pendant ces
trois ans c'était génial merci
et ce devant toulouse beaucoup de gens
qui regardent tp qui sont venus qui
m'ont parlé de l'émission après donc va
tous été remerciés et vous avez pas et
vous avez qui fait le spectacle de jean
luc tout comme bouc été le voir dans
l'équipe par finalement bah moi aussi
voilà alors bernard montiel ludivine
rhétorique benjamin castaldi et kelly
vdo velits en fait vous pensez qu'à vos
gueules
[Rires]
pourquoi ta cb d'hautvillers elle est
lavée quad avec maxime qui ont tourné
les clips la bella et toutes les
conneries là à te dire tu vas revenir
sur terre et boursiers celle ci est allé
deux fois paiement oui ça fait plaisir
parce que je vois que vous êtes venu
avec votre frère jumeau qui lui a lâché
ses cheveux cayla
m
pas du tout
et c'est pas nous allons ses détracteurs
de jean luc lemoine et avec la boîte de
sylvester stallone dans le micro de
gilles maintenant on va écouter jean luc
lemoine matière de fret à dénigrer tas
d'idées sur son chemin la crocodile bas
il a appris qu des débats chez lui il
est le maire ça arrive chez lui mon
frère c'est un truc de ouf et c'est ça
mais tu as tu habites dans combat de
mètres carrés dans mon frère marc un
crocodile mais il a des crocodiles et
prennent le seul ascenseur est la fête
des voisins avec lui j'ai des voisins
très bien à l'émotion pardon excusez moi
on dit oui on l'a mis ça va on sait
mercredi sa journée des enfants
bonjour je m'appelle denise je trouve
cyril hanouna de plus en plus beau dans
votre mission
donc je voulais savoir connaissez vous
un bon opticiens dans le 2e
arrondissement de paris
[Applaudissements]
tout parce que vous n'avez pas besoin
d'aller voir un opticien chardonne is
c'est normal que vous ressentiez ça car
vous avez raison cirer de plus en plus
beau c'est même pas une question de
physique c'est je crois que c'est la
confiance en lui qui est enfin qu'il
acquit le magnifique alors vraiment je
suis un homme qui doute n'est-ce pas
franchement de quoi vous demander aux
filles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de là lui je connais très bien nous
appelle dans la loge pour dire ce que
vous pensez que ça vient ça vient ça ça
me va bien ou pas c'est vachement qu'il
a confiance au lit on pourrait faire une
expérience si on coupait toute la
lumière du plateau le seul qu'on verrait
d'angoissé cyril aellen parce que c'est
vrai moi je suis fleurissant dans la
nuit je sais bien c'est ce qu'on appelle
laura moi je sais que j'ai un stabilo
l'a pas eu est-ce que vous en rêvez pas
trop d'un seul coup puisque les autres
frères accepter tout ça je vais y aller
aujourd'hui c'est abriel qui vous
regardent bizarre non mais parce que
j'ai l'image en tête
brian tu voulais vous faire surligner un
jour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors comment fait-il pour avoir autant
confiance en lui cyril bat déjà il ya la
réussite mais surtout il ya jean michel
maire qui depuis sept ans lui a
tellement l'échelle derrière mais
tellement les cd avec maintenant on
dirait du marbre je me laissais les
boules mais c'était déjà prises au beau
boulot il a tout poli extatique langue
râpeuse pison alors pour ceux qui
voudraient faire ça chez eux une bonne
nouvelle jean michel a un projet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chats russie a monté ça c'est bon
c'est
[Musique]
soit
[Applaudissements]
les catholiques aujourd'hui parce qu'on
voulait vraiment les petits filaments à
chaque jour les faits en fin d'émission
où courent comme des façons ça se voit
ça se savoure ça crépite dans la langue
oui merci c'est jérôme darling alors
quelqu'un comme jo le ciel vous avez vu
ça vous galvanise
mais cyril a tellement confiance en lui
aujourd'hui que parfois on va dire la
vérité il s'égare on pense que ce que je
vais vous montrer
c'est un des plus jolis moments de
solitude de l'année on recevait le
chanteur gibel winne a white aussi sympa
et pas sur quoi mais je vois pas où il
est venu nous faire deux morceaux 2
sympa avec juste un petit break entre
les deux ouais avec sa retenue
habituelle est venu sur le plateau en
criant pour cent que c'était fini
regardez bien les yeux du chanteur et du
budget ont fait une petit train sera qui
m'ont regardé aussi comment l'air de
rien syrie va faire un demi tour comme
ça
cinq ans de plus dans l'histoire
légendaire de cyril
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ap
viva la vida
si vous avez un petit peu mal un accord
du g20 donnent pas tous le soirs jib
alwihda penser mais sans rigoler c'est
que ça je m'en rappellerai que personne
n'avait vu ça ouais ouais c'est vrai
passer tout seul
oui oui mais personne n'a rien dit j'ai
pas un gars idées j'aime bien bonjour
moment de solitude que j'ai aussi parlé
de jean michel maire au nom de mercy qui
s'est pris un magnifique vent avec miss
prestige national
on a les banques au mérite 1 alors je
sais pas s'il avait envie de lui
raconter sa vie pour l'impressionner ou
si vous voulez juste parle à quelqu'un
parce qu'il n'a pas d'amis mais en tout
cas ça sera pas intéresser du tout mais
alors là vraiment pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que me fascine ashton qui est
magnifique et elle était là pour le tpp
ouvert à tous en fête et elle est
malentendante
elle lit sur les lèvres mais quand vous
lui peut parler lt va donc rien contre
vous elle était appareils elle entendait
quand même et je crois qu'elle n'était
pas intéressée du tout à 90% que je
devais l'aider
voilà merci mon coup de coeur maintenant
la venue de daniel et arthur dans tpm p
vous savez ce qu'ils font studio danièle
nouy j'adore 1 sur le net n'est ce pas
[Rires]
des limitations
alors daniel on avait déjà vu sur un
prime elle avait sauté en parachute avec
valérie bénaïm mais là c'est la première
fois qu'il venait en invité je crois
qu'elle s'est régalé et nous aussi parce
que franchement ça ça fait du bien de
découvrir un regard neuf sur l'émission
[Musique]
incroyable ça fait drôle de voir en vrai
on prend des coups
déjà pas tout choix
[Applaudissements]
et dans l'émission d'hier il y avait
michel cymes est ce que michel cymès a
été meilleur que vous je ne sais pas
mais voilà c'est fini
non
google l'auteur et acteur global
internet
c'est très sympa mais si j'ai way
sa marque mère était là
aux 300
on a des manques tu veux moi
alors
aussi un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme d'habitude après chaque média
l'année pour tous cas dans la loge et
bien si bien
[Applaudissements]
à gaza où les d'hier vous êtes toujours
très bonne et je le sais roxanne rheault
kg n'est pas constitué visage
non c'est vous dire et les photos
d'identité de son c'est que la wii que
pour les photos d'identité de gauche je
pose la dispersion de sport et c'est
fini tu commences trois fils dont celle
ci non mais c'est parce qu'il vous aime
bien mais j'avais peur pris nos profits
vous êtes magnifique 11 avec merci
beaucoup
non mais vous non je parle j'ai voulu
faire comme dans les after de rendez
vous en terre inconnue j'ai gardé des
images non diffusées
voilà je sais pas où les mettre mais en
même temps je veux jouer pas m'en passer
une jolie chanson pour finir
[Musique]
vient la 20
notre jeu
[Musique]
nous aurons pas là
la série
merci
en parlant de ça j'avais j'ai jamais un
accident pendant une compétition de
papier à lallaing en rapport avec la
vidéo parce que parce que c'est très
moulant ses chammari dénonçe rigolé un
accident genre notamment vous invite
vous êtes mal pendant une compétition un
mois non mais il y en a qui ont déjà
vomi sur glace
ouais ouais ouais c'est comme au
lidonight vos missions de la nasa
non mais c'est fois c'est vrai il le
stress aussi le stress et ont fait une
pirouette et pulsion le garder nos
jeunes cadres je pense que j'ai vu mes
gars daniel se demander si on l'écoutait
ouais les gens qui n'ont pas compris que
j'entendais tout il n'ya pas que daniel
même des gens qui travaillent tous les
jours sur cette émission ils ont
toujours pas percuter si vous partez en
vacances avec on part tous ensemble en
vacances si vous êtes obligé de coucher
avec ce serait avec qui ça oblige il n'y
a pas de cas tiers commence à dire si
besoin
c'est même pas une conversation privée
il ya tout plus vite qui écoutent du rap
à une question que s'ils posent au micro
lors d'une opération pardon et du coup
on aura bien que tu es obligé ya pas de
katia non
ludivine mais même si le divine
avec toi diane de quoi le devine avec
toi on va au sommet direct sa mère mais
il fait pour l'expérience isabelle oui
bah écoute va dans les grottes de
lascaux n'ont pas lu je vais vous venez
d'où là je vais me faire un épisode de
julie lescaut médias qui vise à aller
dans ces cas là on se dit que c'est bien
d'enchaîner alors hanche et ont tout de
suite et que le top gène ans c'est la
compilation des petits moments étranges
qui ne se passe que dans tp
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un truc de ouf elle et elle fait
un carton en asie et le titre il s'est
classé 19e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
premier fait à l'audience
[Musique]
j
à d'abord je regagne brigade merci
d'être iphone et en direct
qu'est-ce qui les mine où le petit en
plus un petit moment de panique et
périront dessus excellent leçons alors
jean py met dans ce top j'ai dansé
d'autres fans de jean michel mais non ce
serait plutôt lui rendre hommage à l' on
ne se rend pas assez compte de la
difficulté de sa fonction de sniper
officiel il faut être réactif et précis
et surtout drôle sur tous les sujets
tous les sujets qui passe et c'est très
compliqué parce que parfois on à la
vanne mais vous allez voir on n'arrive
pas la placer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui un coup de coeur pour la sympathie
et le professionnalisme de jef pana
klopp qui a tenu à se rendre sur salut
les terriens il a promis à thierry qui
venait et ben il est venu regarde
[Musique]
parce que ça doit coûter des sous mais
il a dit il va venir je vais le faire
quand même bravo à lui a laissé les
moyens j'ai un petit coup de coeur aussi
[Musique]
on réussit une énergie toujours aux
mêmes préventions lecture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rapport officiel
ouais c'est le problème à l'est il est
temps de passer à tous qu'on n'aurait
pas voulu voir et entendre cette semaine
et on commence par la télé par était
dans la tête à tête de lisandro qui a
priori ne s'attendait pas aux
présentations des chroniqueurs par
laurent baffie
même quand il fait une fellation
matthieu delormeau articule plus que lui
maxime gagné
si elles ouvraient une banque du sperme
les donneurs ferait la queue à gâteau
pauvres
[Applaudissements]
je reste ici c'est quoi sniper officiel
bah oui et bientôt vous mettrez
l'ugtt
et les deux la cemac terme en l'amour ça
suffit ouais c'est ça à asus kelly gala
le sdk bande d'hypocrites elles peuvent
pas se blairer tacle aux divines fuck
you tube
oui bien sûr parce qu'il n'est pas bien
mon bungie d'amour célibataire puis ces
débats vous n'avez pas le rester
longtemps d'être magnifique je pense
sincèrement que vous méritez mieux
[Applaudissements]
la morosité la de rayon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas tous
[Musique]
il est ministre
vous allez rire
premier la gran de picole c'est donc un
gramme de picole jean-luc l'anagramme de
picole castaldi
c'est un résultat